it's great to welcome to the program
today David Epstein who's the author of
the New York Times best seller range
wide generalists triumph in a
specialized world also the best-selling
book the sports gene as well today we'll
be talking about generalists in a
specialized world David great to have
you on thank you for having me
so this is a super interesting topic to
me because if you read some of the
scholarship about the future of work in
the United States and the types of jobs
that are more and less likely to be
automated away one of the things that
often comes up is jobs that require sort
of working in the gray areas subjective
advice interpretation of material etc
are less likely to be automated away and
that very often those are the types of
jobs that are more rather than less
specialized that the more general tasks
are easier to automate away but in your
book you talk about actually the value
of generalist knowledge general
knowledge rather than specialization in
the modern world so let's start there
like why do you believe that that's so
important I would say that historically
actually the opposite has been true that
it's the specialist jobs to get out of
them automated away so one of the
examples I talk about in the book is
chess right where chess is what's called
a kind learning environment it's what's
a psychologist robin Hogarth turned to
kind learning in term to kind learning
environment which means it's based on
repetitive patterns essentially
informations clear the task next year
will look like it did last year
the experts advantage in fact is based
on static rules and the ability to
recognize patterns and in a scenario
like that specialization is an enormous
advantage so in fact if you haven't
started studying chess patterns by the
age of 12 your chances of ever becoming
an international master drop from about
one in four to about one in 55 but
that's also why chess is so easy to
automate because it's based on static
rules and repetitive patterns and we see
similar things in other parts of the
work world to give an example that I can
sort of tell quickly I guess when the
ATM came online the prophecy was that
the bank teller would be extinct
overnight but in fact as we've had more
bang
more ATMs in America we've had more bank
tellers and that's because ATMs make
each bank branch cheaper to operate and
so you need fewer tellers but banks open
more branches you end up with more total
tellers but it completely changes the
job from one of repetitive transactions
to one of someone who is more of a
marketing professional and a customer
service agent and they have to have this
much broader range of often much sort of
softer skills and that that actually
looks like the pattern when you actually
look at what happens as opposed to to
what people predict and are not
accountable for those predictions yes
and much to the dismay of many people
having to be sold things every time they
go in and just want to deposit a check
are you sure you don't want to open up a
new CD or whatever yeah I certainly have
experienced that there's a big analogy
here I want to get into the work side
more but there is a big analogy here to
sports that there are lots of analogies
to sports in fact of specialists versus
generalists can you talk a little bit
with some of the sports examples that
you cite about ways to think about
generalist versus specialist in some
particular sports contexts sure well I
mean the the book some partly came out
of a debate I was set up to have with
Malcolm Gladwell right about the 10,000
hour rule it's on on YouTube and
basically his hypothesis was that early
specialization in sports is an
insurmountable advantage and I was the
science writer at Sports Illustrated at
the time and so I went and looked at
what research had to say and in fact in
most sports when scientists look at
athletes who go on to become elite they
find that they have what's called a
sampling period where they learned this
broader range of skills that scaffold
later learning they play a variety of
sports they learn about their interest
and abilities and they systematically
delay specializing until later than
their peers who plateau at lower levels
now there are some exceptions to that
golf I think is one exception to that
and that's why I open the book comparing
and contrasting Tiger Woods and Roger
Federer golf is the epitome of a kind
learning environment again all the
information is clear you're it's almost
like an industrial task you're trying to
do the same known movements over and
over with as little deviation as
possible whereas in the sports that are
more dynamic which are sort of more a
little bit more toward the end of what
hogarth would call a wicked learning
environment where you can't just do the
same thing over and
essentially in those sports you almost
do pretty much ubiquitously see this
this sampling period this this broad
this broad range of skills gained early
and delayed specialization and is in
fact like one of the hallmarks of the
path to expertise and those other sports
yeah I guess it's easy to imagine well
so NHL goalies today are highly highly
specialized but in many cases they only
became special specialists in being
goalies after they had already become
just generally good hockey players in
their communities in high school maybe
even in college to some degree yeah and
even actually if you look at so I filled
a full page of small of shrunken size
type in the back of the book with
citations showing all you know not all
but many of the studies of delayed
specialization athletes go on to become
elite and one of them is in fact of
current NHL players who did more
unstructured play and sampled more
sports formally or informally than peers
who plateaued at lower levels so you
know sports from volleyball and baseball
football soccer hockey those citations I
stuck all back there because I thought
people would be interested in being able
to look up whatever sport whatever their
favorite sport was basically so to bring
this back to careers in thinking about
jobs I mean there are lots of careers
where there is this natural flow of
being a generalist and then specializing
I mean everybody starts other than I
guess dentists and podiatrists maybe
there's some other exactly exceptions
everybody starts going to medical school
whether you end up in psychiatry or
thoracic surgery and then there is a
sort of natural flow at which you start
to specialize sometimes it relates to
the residency that a period that that
you have in the law people start with a
very similar first-year law curriculum
and then eventually you start to
specialize sometimes through an
internship is there a sort of general
rule about the transition between being
a generalist
into a specialist that applies more
broadly so think it's sort of depends
right medical school is your more
general in medical school than when you
become a hyper specialist later right
and a hyper specialist now like a
cardiologist used to be the epitome of
specialization in medicine now to be
specialized a cardiologist might be
someone who only works on car
djaq valves you know the little doors
that that let blood in out of the heart
and even the rest of the heart is
outside of their purview and and that's
caused a major problem of over treatment
with things that don't work because all
these specialists are looking at what's
called surrogate markers basically
they're looking at some small part of a
system and assuming that it's a proxy
for the rest of the system and it turns
out that it often isn't so you know
we'll have things like very popular
blood pressure medications and people
who take a die of heart attack and
stroke at the exact same rates just with
lower blood pressure numbers so I think
while the beginning of med school is
certainly less specialized than someone
becomes eventually I think there's a
movement and this is this is one of the
pioneers of this i profile in the last
chapter of the book
who's saying look we need to stop we
need to stop beginning med school with
reductionism essentially it's anatomy
and physiology before people learn how
to think about a whole organism in
context and so already in the beginning
of some of those schools I think there's
a pretty pretty good argument to be made
that it's starting with the type of
specialization that's that's sort of
counterproductive in terms of which
direction people go in whether they
specialize or generalize first in sports
it's clear that you should generalize
first in some other areas like when I
look at technological innovation the
biggest impact there are generalists and
specialists and they are defined in that
type of research based on how many
different types of technologies they
work across as categorized by the Patent
Office and the specialists who you know
stick to one or two make contributions
to generalists who go across a whole
bunch of technological classes make
contributions at dilettante who don't go
very deep or very broad don't make big
contributions but the biggest ones come
from the polymath who either start with
an anchored in an area of expertise and
then sacrifice some depth for breadth or
start broad and then sacrifice going
broader for some depth so it doesn't
really matter what direction they take
as long as they as long as they
ultimately get the breadth that is the
ally rather than the enemy of depth so
in a really general sense it would seem
as though in a world where there are at
least questions about how employment is
going to work in 20 years or in 30 years
or whatever that there would be some
kind of obvious superficial advantage to
having more general knowledge and
abilities because of the flexibility
that it would conceivably provide to
allow someone to switch career or
industry more easily than some
one who is a specialist or a hyper
specialist is that something that people
now going into college and choosing
majors should be thinking of or is that
what what appears to be common sense not
actually that that much common sense no
III I do think they should be thinking
about that and I don't even think it
requires changing careers necessarily
because even jobs themselves are going
to change even if you stick with the
same job or career you're going to need
to evolve pretty quickly so this scholar
James Besson who did an amazing job of
documenting sort of technological
disruption over time his one of his
findings is that we're not really going
through an unprecedented time in terms
of the scale of disruption has happened
many times before
it's just that workers may have to
reinvent themselves more times than they
did in the past because of the pace of
the change and so I think that's that's
pretty much gonna be true for everyone
starting with the late baby boomers
actually Bureau of Labor Statistics data
shows that starting with late baby
boomers the average number of jobs from
age 18 to about 50 is 12 and so this
really this this idea of the itinerant
millennial sort of actually started with
the very last of the baby boomers and
it's just accelerating now so I think we
should expect to be having to reinvent
and in fact if you look at so one of the
studies I look at in range is done by an
economist looking at whether these early
or late specialized errs who wins the
trade-off in college right the people
who get into their specialty right away
or those who try a variety of things and
delay sampling and sorry and sample and
delay specializing and what he finds is
that the early specialize errs do jump
out to an income lead because they have
more domain-specific skills but by year
six the later specialized er shoot past
them and then the early specialized errs
have to start quitting their entire
career track and much higher numbers
because they don't have that flexibility
to adapt now when they do quit it's
often to improve their match quality
they find a better fit so there their
growth rates are pretty good so they
should be quitting when they do that but
you know they lose the trade-off in
pretty short order they're made to
choose so early that they often make bad
choices for what they should be doing
and they also don't end up as flexible
so the late specialized errs lose a bit
in the short term but when in the long
term if someone's in the middle of their
career right now in other words they
they're not close enough to retirement
that this is not that big of an issue
for
it's also not early enough that they're
going to be thinking about it in the way
that a college student is going to be
thinking about what are the priorities
and sort of most important things to be
doing at the mid-career level yeah I
think some of it depends on their goals
right so let's say they want to be
become an executive because if they're
in their mid-career that may be
something that they're that they're
targeting so recent research by LinkedIn
on a half-million members found that one
of the best predictors of who would go
on to become an executive was the number
of different job functions that someone
who worked across in an industry so if
they're sort of settled on their
industry you know the the best advice
well this is not my advices from the
chief economist of LinkedIn is to work
across a large number of job functions
each additional job functions saves
about three years on average of
experience in terms of trying to trying
to get to the c-suite I think if they're
more oriented toward you know I think a
way to focus well something else to
remember by the way is that we always
think of I was at a Motley Fool event
recently and they took something from
the introduction in my book to pull the
crowd where they asked what do you think
is the average age of a founder of a
blockbuster startup on the day it was
founded not when it becomes a
blockbuster 25 35 45 or 55 25 was the
overwhelming favorite and then it went
down to 35 and then 45 and 55 and the
answer based on research by MIT and the
Census Bureau is 45 and a half we just
you know just like just like we've heard
the Tiger Woods story of early
specialization but not the Roger Federer
story where he played a dozen different
sports we hear the Mark Zuckerberg story
you know when at 22 he said young people
are just smarter but we don't know the
norm
which is that 45 does these people have
to zigzag a little bit before they know
what to do so one I think that's prime
time to be thinking about starting your
own thing if that's something of
interest to you if it's not I think the
principle to remember is seeking what
economists call match quality which is a
degree of fit between your interests
your abilities and the work that you do
and the better your match quality the
harder you work the more resilient
you'll be as one of the researchers that
quote says when you get fit it will look
like grip that means when people get
into a good spot for themselves they'll
display all the characteristics of grit
anyway like resilience and work ethic so
don't stop trying to triangulate your
best fit run lots of short term
experiments and this this advice is kind
of laid out in more detail in the book
where you keep making sure to try
something new instead of just doing what
you've done so that you can get signal
about work that might better fit your
interest in abilities and you pick up
new skills while doing that so if you
just aim towards searching for match
quality this sort of broadening of your
toolbox happens anyway while you're
seeking out the work that best fits you
and some of the the habits of mind that
that help people to do that you know I
lay out from some of the researchers
who've studied it yeah the book is super
interesting it's called range wide
generalists triumph in a specialized
world we've been speaking with the
book's author David Epstein David such a
pleasure having you on I appreciate it
pleasures all mine